I wanted to Lana and today you guys are
watching my review all the trials fusion
I feel like I would be a really bad
physicist or scientist because every
time someone says the word fusion I feel
the need to yell fusion you can probably
blame dragonball z for that so for those
who don't know the trails games have
been around since those cool browser
based flash games that we used to play
at school and lunch times and stuff and
they are basically physics-based
motorbike games where you can accelerate
brake or lean back and forwards to try
and balance yourself Bobo these
ridiculous maps now I played all the
trials games and I've loved every single
one of them but they are plagued with
being really really similar but i think
that Ubisoft and red links have been
aware of this and they have made some
changes the physics system is exactly
the same the gameplay is basically
exactly the same and all of that part of
it is still just as perfect as ever
though asphalt so you have the better
score you get in a track and then it
helps you to unlock harder tracks and
you keep going forward through the game
but in trials fusion they have some
other things included as well one its
kind of futuristic which is cool so I
guess the trial has a little bit of a
different feel there are still lots of
muddy dirty tracks with planks and
barrels and things that we have to try
and get yourself over but it sort of
does look like a different game so
that's good on this one there are
challenges on every single track as well
to do a certain amount of flips or
something for the first time there are
also tricks which I didn't really use
that much and I find a little bit
gimmicky basically once you've unlocked
your license and you hold down the right
thumbstick you will automatically do a
trick if you're in the air or something
there's also kind of a story story
there's no in-depth character
development or emotion or anything so
don't worry about all that it would be
really funny if they tried to make I
like film noir kind of story in two
trials though well you're just depressed
and that's why you go in these
ridiculous black eyes that'll be great
what I feel Charles fusion does add the
other games didn't have is a sense of
humor it's like they kind of took the
already ridiculous tracks and threw more
ridiculous stuff in and repetitively and
timing to make it really funny so while
I guess being very
similar to the previous games is a bit
of an issue the trials games are just so
replayable that it is kind of completely
excused and so for what it does and what
we would expect from a trails game it is
pretty much perfect they meant to be fun
arcade games you to play with your
friends or what's your friends die
horribly at which is one of my favorites
would not recommend to people who are
easily frustrated because these games
will have you failing a hell of a lot
but to me that's just part of the appeal
they're a really good challenge so I
guess I would have to say once again you
did an awesome job you'd be self to end
red links and here is a compilation of
me failing at your wonderful game bye
guys you oh there's your face oh oh no
that's fine okay just worked on oh no it
didn't just gonna say it worked out
better than expected but it didn't ah ah
I'll get that oh [ __ ] oh God dear God oh
thought I was doing so well oh come on
come on alright I give up ah suicide it
is once again dry humping the motorbike
oh god oh god oh god oh god no come on
come on
oh he did oh my god I can't believe I
made that and then that happens that's
just great yep sweet what are you even
doing I feel violated oh damn just doing
backstroke just back stroking it Oh mile
wolf [ __ ] that goes my face no I didn't
know what II wouldn't see what happened
then wow okay no damn it giant flailing
dicks o dicks dicks dicks dicks dicks